hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game that just finished from
round 11 of this year's Tata steel
Masters tournament it is we versus Max
vardam and this game I don't know if
you've seen my previous game notbe
versus women's world champion jujun that
game I'm sure if you've seen it your
head is still spinning so I would
recommend not watching this one if
you've seen the previous one uh you just
might fall out of your chair this game
is so uh I don't know which one is more
complicated but um as usual you guys
will be the the judge of that but uh
yeah I mean there are a lot of chaotic
players in the world but when you're
2740 like Wei and you still have this
style of play you know you you you're
basically the the embodiment of chaos
itself this is this game is so so uh
hard to look at so so difficult to
calculate you will absolutely love it uh
so let's check it out he's facing Max
vadam who uh again is unable to play a
not interesting game even though he lost
the two previous games both of them were
incredibly interesting let's see what
happened here so we with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to E4 H we have
Pawn to E5 and now Bishop to C4 going
for Bishop's opening uh Knight to F6 and
now Pawn to D3 with have Bishop to C5
and now Knight to C3 so still waiting
with the development of the kingside
knight uh Pawn to C6 preparing to strike
in the center with D5 and now Pawn to F4
in the style of the king's Gambit or the
Vienna uh Pawn to D5 now much like you
would you know in in a folk beer attack
against the king's Gambit e captures on
D5 and now Knight to G4 and here uh Wei
actually spent 48 minutes almost 50
minutes on his next move and he played
Knight to F3 and what do you what do you
make of this why is he allowing you know
pieces to land on F2 and should uh
should Max put a piece on F2 and which
piece well uh the answer is no you
definitely shouldn't now Bishop to F2
check uh doesn't really do all that much
King to F1 and if you've ever played the
king's Gambit you know that the king is
perfectly fine on F1 now you have to ask
yourselves okay we we just attack the
Knight where is the uh what's happening
to the bishop what's happening to the
Knight now you're just going to have to
trade you're going to have to play
Knight E3 check and after everything
gets traded okay nothing spectacular
Happening Here F captures on E5 white
has a wonderful Center here for example
Knight captures Bishop Knight captures
um after Pawn captures and uh yeah it's
the the bishop here is hanging you have
to move it then the queen comes into the
game you can Castle so uh not Castle but
you can move the King get the Rook into
the game and everything is perfectly
fine so Bishop to F2 not uh not the most
precise but you know if you ever played
the king's Gambit you know that you
should not do that however Knight to F2
does look very appealing attacking the
queen and the Rook uh but here we's idea
after thinking for almost 50 minutes was
Queen to E2 and now after Knight
captures Rook on H1 Queen captures on E5
with check and after Queen T blocking
and now you're probably wondering okay
there's no attack why' you give up The
Rook it's a full Rook uh the idea was
Knight to E4 and now you probably can't
believe that this is even possible C
captures on D5 or you capture the queen
and you give him the full Center because
the knight uh is not escaping from there
the Knight here also covers the F2
Square so C captures on D5 Bishop
captures and now Queen captures on E5
but now Knight captures on E5 and the
bishop on C5 is hanging so you can't
Castle here you're going to have to move
the Bishop Bishop to B6 the engine is
saying Bishop to G1 but let's you know
be reasonable here Bishop to B6 and now
Knight captures on F7 and this is as
good as lost for black if you Castle
then you run into a lot of nasty
discoveries here for example Knight D2
F6 um Knight F to D6 with check and
after the king moves you will take the
bishop here and after Rook captures on
C8 now Bishop captures on B7 attacking
the Rooks here and if Knight to A6
connecting the Rooks you don't care
you're just going to play C3 prevent
Rook captures and C2 and after something
like Knights to C5 you're going to just
capture Bishop captures Rook captures
you're going to trade here captures
captures play D4 and eventually okay for
the moment you're down a piece but you
will win the Knight so it's not a
problem something like Bishop to D6
Bishop to E3 you're going to move the
king and to win the Knight or probably
the Knight will have to give up give
itself up for you know at least missing
up White's Pawn structure but then white
will just be up um many pawns so that's
the problem here uh so after thinking
for some 25 minutes after this Knight to
F3 move Max does not go for Knight to F2
he actually castles and now Knight to F2
does look very like a very serious
threat but we just doesn't care he plays
F captures on E5 and he invites Max to
go Knight to F2 which he does Knight to
F2 and it's perfectly fine you even
should play this uh we have Queen to E2
and now Knight captures on H1 so for the
moment we is down a full Rook but uh he
continues the attack Bishop to G5 goes
after after the queen now comes Queen to
A5 and okay what's his idea Here pawn to
D6 just creating a pass Pawn here uh
still being down a full rook and uh how
should Max continue this well the
problem is you can't really bring the
Knight back into the game uh due to D4
and okay the Knight will hang next move
so after D6 uh just Bishop to G4 this is
the proper way to continue for Max now
comes Bishop to E7 just attacking The
Rook uh Knight to D7 Max with very much
uh love to give up some material back to
you know ease the pain but we says Nope
Here Comes the Pain Pawn to E6 and how
do you react here if you capture then
comes the bishop captures attacks your
Bishop on G4 so you have to capture and
then after Queen captures with check you
will also lose the Knight on D7 and
white will just be winning here so you
can't do this so instead after Pawn to
E6 we have Bishop to A3 this is again
very nicely played by Max uh trying to
overload that pawn on B2 which is
defending the Knight on C3 uh but just e
captures on F7 with check King to h8 and
here way e castles Queen side he goes
right into Queen captures on C3 as the
pawn here is pinned so okay Queen
captures on C3 and he goes B captures on
A3 and he invites the queen to capture
on A3 but it's not um the best way to go
about things if you play Queen captures
on A3 King B1 and queen to B4 with check
you can just block Bishop to B3 and
still what do you do your Rook here will
be captured your knight will be Capt AP
so he might capture here as the bishop
is pinned the bishop cannot recapture
but now just play Rook captures on H1
and after Pawn to A5 trying to go after
the bishop Queen to E1 and now you have
to trade Queens uh otherwise you know
the queen is coming to H4 the Knight is
coming to G5 and black will have all
sorts of problems here so you will trade
here but the end game is just better for
white that's the that's the problem even
though black is up the exchange white
has the pass Pawn on D6 and that's much
more important has the bishop pair uh
White will be better here so the way to
continue this and this was not played by
Max is to play B5 or even better Pawn to
A5 and then Pawn to B5 and now look at
this super sharp line Bishop captures on
f8 Knight captures on f8 now Pawn to A4
sort of stopping B5 but not really Pawn
to B5 Bishop to B3 captures on A4 Bishop
to C4 and now Rook to B8 looks very
strong but here comes Queen to E8 and it
looks very scary but it would uh
probably go with something like Queen to
B2 with check King D2 Knight to F2 you
you don't have to worry about this as
The Rook covers the Knight and the queen
covers The Rook on B8 so it's you know
everything's taken care of Rook to F1
just going after the Knight the Knight
has no squares Queen to B4 check King to
E2 and now of course you have to do
something the Knight will fall so you're
going to play Knight captures on D3
Bishop captures you're going to
eliminate the D6 pawn and now King to F2
Bishop captures on F3 and now King
captures on F3 and here uh let's say
something like G6 assuming that you
would be able to find all of this black
can still sort of uh play but it will be
white who will be better uh however a A5
the the the strongest continuation or B5
was not played Max played Bishop
captures on F3 and now look at this G
captures on F3 and now Knight to E5
preparing Knight captures on C4 but here
the game is completely winning for Wii
however only if he finds one incredibly
strong move so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea for way
uh while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as I I I I
I do not believe you were able to do it
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is King to B1 this is
the only move that wins the game okay
you could go Bishop cap and f8 and then
King to B1 but you have to play King to
B1 it's way cooler to play King to B1
first uh and and to give you a quick
reason why let's say you play Pawn to F4
uh the simple Knight captures on C4 D
captures and now Queen to A1 check uh is
a force to draw King to D2 you're going
to play Queen to D4 with check and after
King to E1 you have this queen to G1
with check beautiful um geometry here
and after King to D2 you just repeat
Queen to D4 check and so on if King
comes to C1 then you can even capture on
F4 and it might even be black who's
better so you're going to have to settle
for a repetition however after we played
King to B1 now there there's no such
possibility now if you go Knight
captures and C4 D captures there's no
move for black this is just dead lost
what you you have to go after Rook
captures on F7 but now comes D7 and
black resigns how do you stop d8 you you
just don't so that's why after King B1
Queen to D4 was played sort of uh
reinforcing that D7 square and preparing
Knight captures on C4 but now just Rook
captures on H1 so uh you know it's move
19 and only only now way takes back this
little bit of material Knight captures
on C4 D captures and now Queen to B6
with check but just King to C1 uh and
here we have Rook captures on F7 and now
how do you play this well D7 would be a
bit premature if you play D7 first then
comes Queen to D4 and now okay the
queening square is guarded by the queen
and by The Rook you would very happily
give up The Rook for this opponent
bishop and after Rook to D1 there's
again the problem of Queen to A1 check
King to D2 Queen to D4 check King E1 and
queen to G1 with check uh forcing um a
repetition so instead after Rook
captures on F7 Rook to D1 by way in the
style of Adolf Anderson although you
know his move is Rook eight to D1 but
okay you know we're not picky here uh
Rook F to f8 trying to help out with the
defense of the back Rank and also hoping
that way takes the Rook on f8 even
though even that would not save you uh
Pawn to D7 and now there's really
nothing more for uh for Max to do uh
Rook to G8 was played now comes Queen to
E5 and now believe it or not uh his King
is so safe on C1 even though his
defenses are shattered uh look at the
pawns here A2 A3 C2 C4 uh his plan is
just to play F4 F5 F6 and win the game
that's his plan and there's nothing Max
can do about that Max plays Rook eight
to d8 again hoping that we takes some
material but we Again In Cold Blood Pawn
to F4 he's just going to push that pawn
uh so Pawn to C5 trying to get some if
F5 maybe Queen to H6 check even though
even that is lost uh but now we does
take the material Bishop captures Queen
captures on d8 and queen captures on C5
and he was in this position un move 27
that Max vardam resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
he also had a minute and a half on the
clock which I mean is not enough you
know for anything and um his position is
dead lost so that's the that's the
beauty of sacrifice way ye sacrificed
you know in the style of Old Masters and
the that's uh you know sort of the Mind
Over Matter approach you give up
material to gain the initiative and
later on you you build up so much
initiative that you can just trade it
for all the material you want and you
know Max was trying to give back
material uh but even though he throw you
know he he thrown all of this material
back at way it was still not enough to
survive the game because now okay the
the initiative settled down but the
material difference is just too great
and there's no way of course um to
continue this game uh even it's I mean
it's not even about material it's the
the pass Pawn on D7 is too strong and
there's just no way to continue playing
this there's no move you can make here
you can never move the queen uh you you
know uh the there there's nothing here
the the the pawns will just start
marching forward you will put a queen on
D6 to always have d8 ready if the black
queen moves then you start advancing
this Pawn you start advancing this Pawn
if it comes to H6 then you also open up
this D Al there are so many winning
ideas here that um of course
Max has no no uh reason or or you know
even the will to continue playing this
game uh so yeah beautifully done by way
uh quite a quite a spectacular win only
27 moves against Max vam but that's the
thing Max he's an incredibly interesting
player he always plays the the most
interesting games and even though he
lost uh well you know counting this one
he lost three of his previous games all
of them are definitely worthy to see and
all of them are absolutely incredible
but what are you going to do you win
some of them you lose some of them I
think in 2021 it was it was in fact his
game that got the award of the queen
sacrifice of the year or the game of the
year on this channel uh so you know do
check it out if you uh if you have the
time I will even put it first link in
the description below uh you know as he
lost three games do check out that one
and uh you know you can even praise him
a little bit in the comments of that
video uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely done
done by by we I will now spoil the
result of the gukesh versus alza game so
if you haven't seen it don't watch the
video any longer ala and GES Drew their
game which means that as Notre Beck won
the game uh Notre Beck is now the sole
leader of the tournament but two more
runs to go anything can happen you know
just incredibly incredible stuff I I
I'll keep you guys informed uh so that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it the
the way there we have it the embodiment
of chaos itself
I mean what a guy I would like to I
would like to thank Christopher and Ruth
burette Usman AAL
Minas Teresa bullet.com and Lana is the
best wife in the world for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day